[Music]
in about one year's time the
long-awaited sequel to avatar will be
released after a total of 13 years with
box office takings of around 2.85
billion us dollars the movie bad its
competitor avengers end game again by a
hair's breath and in addition to its
story about the navi people is
especially known for the beautiful world
of the moon pandora in today's original
we present everything we know about the
upcoming avatar 2 from the story to the
cast and the potential titles of the
plan for sequels
but before we get to part 2 let's rewind
to the beginning after all what was the
first part of avatar all about of course
you will encounter some spoilers in the
synopsis since we want to focus on the
plot of everton 2 afterwards basically
the plot revolves around jake sully born
in 2126 who joined the marines at a
young age and was injured so severely
that he's now paralyzed from the waist
down this is not really a good starting
point for exploring an alien planet but
a tragic incident results in him
traveling to pandora instead of his twin
brother after several years in
cryostatic sleep aboard a spaceship he
finally arrives on the beautiful and
pristine planet with a few other humans
and is initiated into the details of his
mission which is to mingle with the
native people the na'vi and find out
their vulnerabilities behind the whole
operation is the resources development
administration or rda for short they in
turn are very keen on the raw material
on obtainium which is available in large
quantities on pandora since the human
organism on the alien planet is anything
but capable of living the rda has come
up with something special the talk is of
a scientific project that has created a
genetically modified hybrid of human dna
and navi dna these so-called avatars can
be controlled by humans because the
human brain and all nerve endings are
connected to the avatar for jake in
particular this is a most extraordinary
experience because in his avatar body he
does not feel the impact of his
paraplegia and can thus move freely
already during his first scouting
mission things go wrong and he's
separate from his group soon he's
confronted with a pack of viper wolves
and defends himself in an actually
hopeless fight luckily for him a native
navi comes to his aid and drives the
dangerous animals away jake is directly
fascinated by the beautiful navi who
bears the name nathiri he quickly learns
about the customs and culture of the
navi people and finds himself in a
fateful dilemma for the more he learns
about naitiri and her way of life the
more indecisive he becomes about his
mission jake must therefore decide whose
side he's on because no matter what he
has the fate of the peace-loving people
in his hands now you should have
refreshed your knowledge about the first
part back then avatar is set of a real
3d hype which is why the film often has
to put up with the allegation that
visitors only went to the movies because
of the 3d and not for the story however
it is clear that star director james
cameron has a lot more up his sleeve
when you realize that the 67 year old
has planned a total of four sequels for
the franchise
let's now turn our attention to the
possible plot of avatar 2. after the
brilliant end of the first part the
humans were successfully expelled from
pandora slowly but surely peace returns
to the almost colonized navi and jake
has now fully become one of them almost
13 years after the story of the first
part he has even brought offspring into
the world namely his children natalya
lock and tuktieri most recently producer
john landau announced news about this
story in early december in an interview
with total film magazine he announced
that the sullies will meet the met kaina
people and have to hide from the rda's
exploitation missions the human
occupiers of pandora just do not
surrender to the inhabitants and are
preparing for another attack on
pandora's resources and population
landau further revealed that cameron has
managed to incorporate many different
themes that will appear to every viewer
nonetheless the story of the young sully
family with all its ups and downs will
be the main focus in addition the
producer confirmed that the scripts for
all the sequels had already been
completed before the first shooting even
began with such an extensive series of
movies planned this comes as no surprise
by the way lando is sure that you can
watch avatar 2 without any previous
knowledge from the first avatar movie
meaning it is not absolutely necessary
to watch the whole movie again our
summary of part 1 is therefore
completely sufficient
interestingly director camera announced
even before the release of the first
part that he wanted at least two sequels
to follow success proved him right for
what was then one of the most expensive
productions in film history after the
blockbuster quickly climbed the ladder
of the most successful movies of all
time it was also clear that sooner or
later it would be resumed the plan was
to shoot back to back in new zealand
cameron hired different screenwriters
for their respective scripts of avatar 2
to 4 and assigned them each their own
film as a result josh friedman wrote
part 2 rick jaffa and amanda silva part
3 and shane salerno part 4. solely for
part 5 there is currently no
scriptwriter james cameron who is
certainly not a man of few words also
revealed that he would like to use
footage from the mariana trench the
deepest point on earth as a model for
the underwater world of pandora
regarding 3d technology cameron likewise
announced nothing less than revolution
one innovation is to shoot the film at
60 frames per second to achieve better
and above all smoother 3d in addition
there are persistent rumors that avatar
2 could be seen in 3d in theaters
without the need for glasses and that
would indeed be another revolution the
problem with this is that movie theaters
would have to upgrade to the new
technology and invest a lot of money
which is a pretty unlikely scenario
especially given the pandemic and the
lack revenue cameron is and remains one
of the great visionaries on the movie
business which leads us to hope that
avatar 2 will not only feature great 3d
technology but above all a gripping
story
next let's look at the cast of avatar 2.
needless to say some familiar faces are
making a comeback including sam
worthington as jake zoe zaldana is
nathiri also joining the cast are sigone
weaver as dr grace augustine stephen
lang as colonel miles courage matt
gerald as corporal lane weinfleet and
giovanni ripsey as parker selfridge for
some of them it is certainly worth
asking what exactly their appearance
will be like in part 2 since not all of
them made it through the big battle in
the first part of life much more
exciting however are the new additions
which as you would expect from a big
hollywood blockbuster are quite
impressive so far titanic actress kate
winslet is set to join the cast as the
water person ronal while michelle joe
has been cast as dr karina moog eddie
falco has been signed on for the
villainous role of general artmar cliff
curtis will play the leader of the
makaina clan jermaine clement will
become scientist doctor ian garvin and
david thule's a new character named
palak all in all a respectable cast with
possibly a few more names to be added
for instance it seems pretty certain
that vin diesel will be involved in the
avatar sequels whether this already
concerns part 2 is currently unknown
various sequel titles have been
circulating among the avatar fan
community for several years now as it is
considered highly unlikely they will
remain with lackluster avatar 2. back in
2018 the bbc brought up four possible
titles which cameron himself even
confirmed is possible but not final
titles there are thus four titles for
four sequels though it is not known
which one is intended for which sequel
the first one is called avatar the way
of water and based on the water theme it
could perfectly complement part 2 yet
also part 3 since both sequels are
supposed to focus on the underwater
world another potential title is avatar
the seedbearer this could be a reference
to the seeds of the tree of souls which
is considered to be the most sacred
place in pandora and was largely
responsible for the complete
transformation of jake's soul into his
avatar body the next title is avatar the
tolkien rider
so far nothing is known about the so
called tolkien in the avatar franchise
but the term toku can be found and
buddhism with means something like a
reincarnated person who passes on his
knowledge to new generations in
connection with the word ryder it could
of course also simply be a new living
being on pandora the last title is
called avatar the quest for ewa egua is
the deity of the navi who connects all
beings on the planet and generally
stands for the life energy of pandora
hence one could possibly go on a quest
for iwa in the sequel since the parts
before life has gone extinct in an
alarming way and the decay of the planet
is imminent another possibility would be
that one must solve a certain task for
ewo
you can already see we can only
speculate here which title would you
assign to which sequel
feel free to discuss this with us in the
comments
fortunately for many fans producer john
landa regularly posts updates and behind
the scenes footage on his instagram
account there you can see all kinds of
technically sophisticated shooting work
which shows various underwater creatures
some concept art and snapshots with
actors in front of the camera to discuss
every single picture would surely go
beyond the scope here since by now there
are several dozens of images that are
all worth a look in january for example
we were allowed to see a beautiful
meccan village on the water although
this is sadly concept art and not an
actual scene from the film a different
example from last october shows a fully
equipped high-tech rda laboratory and
one example from august 2020 illustrates
quite well the immense amount of work
involved in shooting the mammoth project
as here you can see part of the movie
set in a large hall in new zealand all
custom made to james cameron's liking of
course just in time for world ocean's
day in june 2021 producer john landau
published a new image via twitter in the
form of concept art it hardly could have
been more appropriate given that the
focus of avatar 2 is on the beautiful
underwater world of pandora of course
you cannot only see the diversity of
species but also a new creature that
looks like a plesiosaurus many fans are
now waiting all the more eagerly for the
first trailer for avatar 2 unfortunately
there are no clues as to when exactly a
trailer or at least a teaser might
appear however in view of the theatrical
release on december 16 2022 a bit of
video material should be expected at the
beginning of this year
how did you like our news video leave
your expectations and theories for
avatar 2 in the comments and be sure to
subscribe to stay updated on the
upcoming blockbusters
see you next time
[Music]
you